[Music] Uh [Music]
Hesitantly obtained a fellowship, and at the time of our cento-
shie priesthood, 200
years
old.
It seemed that the future spread was already
going to be
cheaper, so
it
seemed that they were
judging the seriousness with all of this in mind.  Isn't it intentionally
not revealing the parts that are suitable for international cooperation such as ring dyeing and international cooperation
?
Oh, I think I can think of it
like
this.  Now, the
spread, then
the various symptoms that were in the middle of the spread, and
how well the medical system can handle them, how well the
French cure and various follow-ups can
be systematically supported.
This seems a little bit
worrisome.
[Music]
Since January, North Korea has been rapidly conducting No. 1 testing the
rinse altitude and number of weapons of the opponent quickly, and
whether intended or not
, through the disclosure of the
confirmed clone,  We
have no choice but to adjust the tempo. The
South Korean military captured and wrote three
short-range ballistic missiles launched into the East Sea from the circular area
of ​​Pyongyang, North Korea this afternoon.
We strongly urge an immediate cessation of serious provocations.